okay let's continue speaking to folks
because people want to chat that's just
the reality of what's going on right now
let's go next to chad from florida
hey david hey chad are you in florida or
florida well that depends on who you ask
okay fair okay good
um so my first question or you know
maybe the only one we can get to is
uh do you think the left has sort of
squandered this opportunity
uh to distance themselves from socialism
making an issue of
the embargoes or the authoritarian or
sorry not socialism communism
you know making an issue of the
embargoes or the authoritarian
aspect of the government as opposed to
saying we reject communism you know
bernie sanders isn't a communist he does
he wants to implement
you know some sort of socialized health
care we're not going you know
he doesn't want to be cuba no
i don't i don't think so um let me see
how can i answer this
in sort of the most clear way um
i've seen just about
every prominent democrat say that they
aren't supportive of 60 plus years of
uninterrupted castro family rule
in cuba and at the same time
many of them although not all have made
it clear that the embargo has been
completely counterproductive and that's
that's my position
i don't know that there should be this
expectation of denouncing communism
every time you talk about cuba just does
it doesn't really make sense to me i
mean when i talk about it i just make it
clear
i'm a progressive so i don't support
authoritarian autocratic regimes
run by what are effectively dictators or
minimum authoritarian strong men i make
that clear because
my audience sometimes gets very confused
about what my positions are on these
issues
but i don't think it's it's reasonable
to say every time a democrat talks about
cuba they should denounce communism that
sounds weird to me
okay thanks for the answer my pleasure
my pleasure